[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
CASEY RODRIGUEZ:
--differentiable as many times
as you like.
And the derivative at
0 equals 0 for all n.
Why do I bring this up?
Because then the Taylor
polynomial for this function
that I've written here at 0--
so this is the Taylor
polynomial at 0--
just equals, again, the sum
of the derivatives evaluated
at 0 times x minus 0 to the k.
But all of the
derivatives are 0.
And thus, the
function is, in fact,
equal to the
remainder term near 0.
So you see, the remainder
term carries all of f,
so it doesn't necessarily
need to be small.
And what I'm trying to say is
that in general, you can't just
throw away the remainder
term and expect
that to be even near
the point x, some sort
of faithful representation
of the function
just by the Taylor polynomial.
Because as we see
for this function,
the Taylor polynomial
is identically 0.
If I throw away the remainder
term, I would be saying f is 0,
but it most certainly
is not near x equals 0.
So that was the point
of that discussion.
Now, let's give the proof.
And as you see, we're just going
to kind of apply the mean value
theorem repeatedly to
higher derivatives of f,
but not necessarily of f, but of
a function we cook up out of f.
Let's take two points, x0 and
x, not equal to each other.
Of course, if they're
equal to each other,
we can take C to be whatever
we want, because then, f of--
because then what
we pick up is f of x
equals f of x on
the right-hand side.
So we can just consider the
case that x0 does not equal x.
And let M be--
this is just a number depending
on x and f0 over x minus x0
to the n plus 1.
P sub n This is, again, the
Taylor polynomial of degree n.
f of x minus P sub n of
x over x minus x sub 0.
So this is just a number
depending on x and x0.
Then just rewriting this,
this means that f of x
is equal to P sub n of x,
the Taylor polynomial of n
at x, plus Mx times--
Mx x0 times x minus x sub
0 over n to the n plus 1.
Now, the goal is to show
that, in fact, this number can
be written as the n plus
1 derivative evaluated
at some point over
n plus 1 factorial.
Now, the goal-- show
there exists a C and a B
such that Mx equals f n plus 1
over C over n plus 1 factorial.
Now, what is this
defining characteristic
of this Taylor polynomial at--
this n-th order
Taylor polynomial?
Evaluate with respect to x0.
Well, the point is that
this Taylor polynomial
agrees with f at x0 up to n-th
order, up to n derivatives.
In other words, if I take
the k-th derivative of f
and evaluate it at
0, this is the same
as taking the k-th derivative
of the Taylor polynomial
and evaluating it at 0.
So the Taylor polynomial agrees
with f up to n derivatives
at the point x0.
Again, this is the whole
point of Taylor polynomials,
is that they, at
least at the point,
agree with f up to n-th order.
Does it mean they
agree with f, or even
are a good representation of f,
away from x0 like we just saw?
But at least at x0,
they agree with f.
Now, I'm going to define
a new function, which
I'm going to start applying
the mean value theorem to,
and hopefully come up
with this C. It's g of s
equals f of s minus P sub
n of s minus this number
from earlier times s
minus 0 to the n plus 1.
And something to note is
that this function here,
this whole function, so g--
first off, f is n plus
1 times differentiable.
This is a polynomial, so it's
n plus 1 times differentiable.
And this is just a
polynomial, also.
And s.
So it's n plus 1
times differentiable.
So ns.
Let me draw a picture.
We have x0 and x.
At least in the picture,
x is bigger than x0,
but that doesn't really matter.
What do we know about g of x0?
Well, this is equal to f.
And now, when I stick
in x0 here, I get 0.
And now f of x0 minus P n of x0,
again, by this first thing here
for k equals 0.
This is equal to 0.
And now, what do I know
about g evaluated at x?
This is equal to f
of x minus P n of x.
Remember, the variable that
I'm changing-- or at least,
the free variable there, is s.
So if I stick in x, I
get f of x minus P n of x
minus M, this constant
from earlier, which
I chose depending on x and x0.
But using this relation
here, this is 0.
I have that-- the function
f at x0 and at x is 0.
By the mean value theorem,
or Rolle's theorem--
so by mean value theorem, there
exists a point x1 between x0,
x such that g prime
of x1 equals 0.
Yeah?
Now, remember, at x0--
or g prime of x1 equals 0.
Now, at x0, we have that--
OK.
So at g prime of x1,
at x1, g prime is 0.
But also, if I look at
the derivative of g at x0,
this is equal to f prime of x0
minus P n prime of x0 minus--
now, here, I'm working
under the assumption,
just for illustration
purposes, I'm
assuming n is, say,
bigger than or equal to 2,
at least from what I'm
writing down right now.
But if I take the derivative
of this and plug in x0,
then I will also get 0 here.
So I just get f prime of
x0 minus P n prime of x0.
So this equals 0.
So I have g prime of x1 equals
0, g prime of x0 equals 0,
and therefore, by the mean
value theorem applied again,
there exists a point x2
between x and x0 such
that the second derivative of
g evaluated at x2 equals 0.
And now, I just iterate this.
Because I still know, at x0,
the second derivative of g
is also 0 as long as n is
bigger than or equal to 2.
And then I'll get
that there's x1 here--
let me write here, at this
point, we know g equals 0,
g prime equals 0, and so on.
At this point, g prime equals 0.
And then at x2--
then the fact that g double
prime here at this point is 0.
And here, we apply the
mean value theorem again.
And we get a point,
x3, in between them
where, now, the third
derivative equals 0.
And we can keep going on,
up until a certain point.
And what point is that?
That's when I've taken
away n derivatives here,
and all that I have
left here is s minus x0.
Let me summarize.
Continuing in this way,
we see there exists--
we see for all k
between 0 and n,
there exists an x sub
k between x0 and x such
that the k-th derivative
at x sub k equals 0.
In particular, at the k equals
n stage, what do I have?
x0, x, and this is x sub n.
I'm just now going to repeat
this argument one last time,
and we'll see where
that leads us.
Since g-- the n-th
derivative of g evaluated
at x sub 0 equals
0-- again, this
is coming from
this relation here.
Let me, in fact,
write that again.
This is equal to f of
x0 minus P n of x0.
And I'll even write out, this
is equal to Mx x0 n plus 1
factorial times x0 minus x0.
This is what happens when
I take n derivatives of ns,
of this monomial here.
This, of course, is 0 equals 0.
Since we have that
and we have, it's
equals 0 at this other
point, there exists,
by the mean value theorem,
now applied to g--
the n-th derivative of g.
When I write mean
value theorem here,
I'm not applying it
to the function g.
I'm applying it
to the derivative.
Here, I was applying
it just to g.
the mean value theorem
to the derivative of g.
And, here I'm now
applying the mean value
theorem to the n-th
derivative of g.
Let me make that
perfectly clear.
There exists a number, C,
between x and x0 such that
the n plus 1-- the
derivative of g,
the derivative of the n-th
order derivative of g,
so the n plus 1st
derivative of g--
of C equals 0.
But what does this mean?
Now, if I take n plus 1
derivatives with respect
to s of this over here, I get f.
Now, if I take n plus 1
derivatives of an n-th degree
polynomial, I get 0.
If I take two derivatives of
a degree 1 polynomial, which
is just x, I get 0.
If I take three derivatives of
a degree 2 polynomial, I get 0.
So I get 0 for when I
differentiate n plus 1 times
an n-th degree polynomial minus
this constant again times n
plus 1 derivatives of
this monomial here in s.
Remember, all of
these derivatives
I'm writing down here,
these are all in terms of s.
Times n plus 1 factorial.
And this equals 0.
This is just this
here expressed here.
And it should be C, I'm sorry.
Because we're plugging in C.
But that means
precisely that, which is
what I wanted to show existed.
At this point C, this constant
from earlier, which, remember,
was defined in this
way, is actually
equal to the n plus 1 derivative
of f evaluated at some C.
And therefore, f of x is
equal to P n of x plus--
x C times-- where C
is between x and x0.
Again, Taylor's theorem
says a couple of things,
but it doesn't say
certain things.
The mean value theorem,
as it's written,
says there exists some point in
between so that the secant line
from f of b to f of a is
equal to the derivative
of the function, the
tangent to the graph,
at some point in between.
But it doesn't tell you that
the function near a point
can necessarily--
what am I trying to say?
What Taylor's
theorem does say is
that you can iterate
the mean value theorem
for higher-order derivatives.
But what it doesn't say is that
this polynomial that you get
over here, which
you interpret kind
of as an approximation of
the function f near x0,
it doesn't say
that approximation
is necessarily good.
Because we just saw
from this example
that that remainder term may end
up being the entire function.
But still, that doesn't
make it any less
useful in applications.
Let's give a simple application
of Taylor's theorem, which
perhaps you had endless
homework problems or exam
problems on back when
you first took calculus
and were finding critical points
and trying to characterize them
as relative minimums
or relative maximums.
We have the second
derivative test,
which says the following--
which states that,
suppose I have a function
from the open interval
a, b to R. And suppose
this has two
continuous derivatives
on this open interval a, b.
If, at a point in a, b,
the derivative equals 0,
and the second derivative
of f, you evaluated it at 0,
x sub 0 is positive, then
f has a relative min at x0.
And I should say that this
is a strict relative min.
What's the difference between
a strict relative min and just
a relative min?
A strict relative min, I
mean that if I'm at any point
other than x0 and
I'm nearby, then
f of x is bigger than f of x0.
Let me just write that here.
That means near x0--
OK.
In fact, let's
just briefly recall
what the definition
of relative min is.
And this will allow me
to state what it means
to be a strict relative min.
This means there exists
a delta positive such
that for all x, n--
such that for all x,
x minus x0 implies
f of x is bigger than f of x0.
This is the definition
of strict relative min.
A strict relative
min is a relative min
because, what's the
only thing missing
from the definition
of relative min
is, what happens if
I evaluate at x0?
And then at x0, we get
f of x0 equals f of x0.
so a strict relative
min is a relative min,
but it's a little bit stronger.
Because it's saying that as
long as x is not equal to x0,
meaning this thing is
bigger than 0, f of x
is bigger than f of x0, not
bigger than or equal to.
I hate doing this, but the
theorem's stated over there,
and now we need to go across
the room to do the proof.
f has two continuous
derivatives on a, b.
And therefore, the second
derivative is continuous at 0.
Since the second
derivative is continuous,
we get that the limit,
as x goes to x0--
or, let me put--
instead of x, say C. This
equals f double prime of x0,
which is positive,
by assumption.
That's what we're assuming.
And therefore, by an exercise
in one of the assignments,
since this limit, this
implies that there
exists a delta 0 positive such
that for all 0 bigger than C,
bigger than x0--
and in fact, we can include--
let me see.
There exists a delta 0
positive such that, for all C,
satisfying--
we get that f prime
of C is positive.
All I'm saying is we
have this point, x0.
x0 plus delta 0.
x0 minus delta 0.
And then on this interval, f
double prime of C is positive.
You proved that, in
fact, in an assignment.
If the limit of a function
as I approach a point
equals l, which is positive,
then near the point,
the function has to be positive.
Now, I have to verify that--
what am I trying to do?
I'm trying to verify that I have
a strict relative minimum so
that there exists a delta--
I have this delta
0, which ensures
that the second derivative
is positive on this interval.
So I say choose delta
to be this delta 0.
And now, I have to show
that this delta works,
meaning for all x
satisfying that inequality,
I have f of x is
bigger than f of x0.
So take an x between delta--
I mean, within delta
distance to x0.
Here's x, say.
Then by Taylor's theorem, there
exists a C between x and x0--
so here's x.
There's this point
C between x and x0,
which I can always choose
strictly in between them, such
that I have that f
of x equals f of x0
plus f prime of x0
times C minus x0 plus--
no, that should be x, sorry--
plus f double prime of C over
2 times x minus m 0 squared.
Now, at x0, the derivative
is assumed to be 0.
We're assuming the
derivative vanishes at x0
and the second derivative
is positive there.
So this equals f
of x0 plus f prime
of C over 2 times
x minus x0 squared.
Now, on this whole interval,
which is where I'm looking at,
f double prime of C is positive.
So this thing here is positive.
And as long as x
minus x0 is not 0--
as long as x is not equal to
x0-- this thing is positive.
This is a square.
So this is strictly
bigger than f of x0, which
is what I wanted to prove.
So I have proven that f of
x is bigger than f of x0
on this interval here.
Of course, the picture
that goes along
with this is something like,
let's say, the point x0, 0,
at least near this point,
the derivative is 0.
The second derivative
is positive.
So this is how the
function should look.
CASEY RODRIGUEZ:
So that concludes
what we're going to say
about differentiation.
I have put in the assignment
the most useful version
of L'Hopital's rule,
which is kind of the only
other main thing we're
missing right now from just
the theory of differentiation.
But remember, differentiation
is a bit of a miracle,
as I've said before,
because there
exist continuous functions
that never have a derivative.
Integration, which is what
we're moving on to now,
is not so much of a miracle.
Because as we'll show,
every continuous function
has a Riemann integral, which
is a different limiting process.
So all of these things
we're talking about,
all of these
notions-- continuity
is a notion that
involves limits.
Differentiation is a
process involving limits,
and integration is a
process involving limits.
But somehow, integration
is not as harsh a process
as differentiation.
We're moving on,
now, to Riemann--
I should say the
Riemann integral,
but I'll say
Riemann integration.
What is Riemann integration?
It is-- you were told this
in calculus, but maybe
in not so careful a way.
This is a theory
of what it means--
or this is a number that
we associate to a function
that you interpret as the
area underneath the curve.
It is not, as maybe
you're told, somehow
magically equal to the
area underneath the curve.
There is no notion of
The Riemann integral
is a number which
you interpret as the
area underneath the curve
because it agrees
with what you think
the area underneath the curve
should be for simple examples.
For example, a
half-circle or just a box.
These two notions agree.
And therefore, you interpret
the Riemann integral,
which is a number obtained
by a limiting process,
as the area
underneath the curve.
It is not somehow,
out in the universe,
there is this notion of
area underneath the curve,
and the Riemann
integral magically
coincides with that notion.
No.
It is a theory, if you
like, of assigning a number
that we interpret as the
area underneath the curve.
And it's good for--
very good for,
especially once we
get to the real
miracle of calculus,
the fundamental theorem of
calculus, which connects
the derivative to
integration-- it's
fantastic in being able to,
in its ease of computing.
Hopefully, at some
point, you go on
to learn about Lebesgue
integration, which
is a much more versatile notion
of area underneath the curve.
And a little bit more robust.
We have better theorems that
you can then use and prove--
prove, then use, of course.
But Riemann integration
is a place to start.
And in fact, in some treatments
of Lebesgue integration,
Lebesgue immigration is treated
as the completion of Riemann
integration, just
as the real numbers
are the completion, in some
sense, of the rational numbers.
Let's set up some definitions
and notions that we'll need.
I'm just going to be talking
about Riemann integration
of continuous functions.
This is the simplest way to go.
Why not for some general
functions or something
like that?
Because in general,
a function does not
have a Riemann integral.
So you could try to ask, can
you characterize what functions
do have a Riemann integral?
And the answer to that is
functions which are continuous,
in a sense, almost everywhere.
Almost everywhere, though,
we don't have the machinery
to describe that.
That's a measure theory course.
Because you cannot--
or at least,
because we don't have the
machinery to fully state what
it means, a precise "if and
only if" statement about when
a function is Riemann integral,
I'm just going to do the ribbon
in a rule for
continuous functions,
which is nice and
simple enough--
and still pretty.
Let me just
introduce, first, some
notation that I'll
be using a lot.
C of a, b.
This is going to be the set
of all continuous functions
from a, b to R. So f from
a, b to R. f is continuous.
Now, as I said, we're going
to associate to an interval
and a function-- a number--
which we will later
interpret as a notion of area
underneath the curve.
This process is a
limiting process where
we're going to be
taking the domain
and cutting it up into
smaller and smaller pieces,
and somehow writing down
a number that we think
approximates the area, is
a good approximate area
underneath the curve.
I'm going to assign some words
to this breaking down process.
Partition of the interval a, b.
This is just a finite
set x underline,
which I'll write in this way.
It's a finite set, which I
write x0, x1, x2, up to xn,
with the property that x0 is
equal to a is less than x1,
less than x2.
The norm of a partition,
which I denote
with these two vertical lines
on either side of x underline,
is by definition, the
max of the differences
between these partition points.
I refer to these points that are
in the partition as partition
points.
This is x1 minus x0, and
so on, xn minus xn minus 1.
A tag for partition x
bar is a finite set xi.
Get used to some Greek
letters in your life.
Xi equals C1 up to Cn.
As before, in the partition,
we started off with a 0 here.
We started off with 1.
Such that each of these xis
lie between partition points.
In other words, x0 is less
than xi 1 is less than x1.
And the pair is referred
to as a tagged partition.
Although maybe it looks a
little bit fancy, it's not.
A partition is, you
take your interval a, b,
and you cut it up into pieces,
with your first point always
being a and your last
point always being b.
So x1, x2, and because
I can't draw n points,
I'm going to draw four points.
x3, x4.
There's a partition
of a, b, into--
think of these points
as being the endpoints
of little intervals that
I've broken up the bigger
interval into.
And the xis are just points in
each of these little intervals.
C1 has to land there.
xi 2 could land in the next one.
It could actually be
the endpoint if we like.
xi 3.
Let's say it's the midpoint.
We'll say xi 4 is there as well.
The tagged points are just lying
in these smaller intervals.
And at least in this picture,
the biggest separation
between partition points
would be something
like x3 minus x2 here.
The norm of a
partition is the length
of the largest subinterval.
I drew kind of
something abstract here.
Let's make this more concrete.
Let's say I'm looking at--
just to write down
a few examples,
let's say my interval
is 1, 3, and then
my partition are the
points 1, 3/2, 2, 3.
And then my set
of tags are 5/4--
just a midpoint-- 7/4, 5/2.
So my partition is 1.
There's 2.
3/2.
Those are my partition points.
And meanwhile, my
tags are the midpoint.
And then the norm
of this partition
is the maximum of the lengths
of these smaller subintervals
here-- not the ones using C,
but the one with the partition
points.
So max of 3/2 minus 1, 2 minus
3/2, 3 minus 2, and is 1--
the length of this subinterval.
Now, given a tagged
partition, we're
going to associate a number to
this tagged partition, which
we interpret as an
approximate area.
Let f be a continuous function,
xi, a tagged partition
the Riemann sum associated to--
I should say, of f--
associated to the tag
partition xi is the number
s sub f of x bar--
I mean, x underline,
xi underline,
which is the sum from k
equals 0 to k equals 1 to n
of f of xi k times
xk minus xk minus 1.
Again, what we interpret
this number as--
how do we interpret this number?
We interpret it as somehow--
we give meaning to this
number as an approximate area.
If this is a, b, and
there's a function f,
and let's say those are
the partition points.
So x1, x2, x3, x4, x0.
And let's say the tags are just
the right endpoints of each
of these smaller intervals.
Then what is this number, at
least in terms of this picture?
That's a little
off, but anyways.
What I've shaded
in, this area, this
equals this Riemann sum of f
associated to this tag here.
And let me go over,
again, the graph of f.
This number here which
we've come up with we
interpret as somehow
being an approximate area.
Again, I don't like saying
area underneath the curve,
because that
presupposes that there
is a notion of the area
underneath the curve
independent of what
we're doing here.
But that's not the case.
We are, in fact,
giving a theory--
a mathematical theory-- of
area underneath the curve.
We are prescribing
a number which
we interpret as the area
underneath the curve.
These Riemann sums we interpret
as being approximate areas.
What we would like
to do is somehow
take a limit as the lengths
of these subintervals
get smaller and smaller, as the
norm of the partitions go to 0.
And what we would like to say is
that these approximate areas--
these are just numbers--
converge to some
limiting number--
a, say.
That number we refer to as
the Riemann integral of f,
and we interpret as the area
underneath the graph of f.
Now, for this to
work, we have to show
that as we take partitions with
smaller and smaller norm, where
the intervals get
smaller and smaller,
these approximate areas actually
do converge to some number.
And that's going to be the
content of the next lecture,
in which we'll prove the
existence of the Riemann
integral and do some
properties about.
So the take-home
point is, again, there
is no definition of area
underneath the curve
independent of what we're doing.
It's not like, out
there in the universe,
there's a notion of the
area underneath the curve,
and when we compute
the Riemann integral,
magically, those two things--
those two numbers-- coincide.
No.
We are giving-- we
are constructing
a theory of the area
underneath the curve, which,
for example, for a half-circle,
or square, or ellipse,
do, in fact, coincide
with stuff you
know from ordinary geometry.
And therefore, it
gives a good theory
of area underneath the curve.
But in order for us to
construct that theory,
or how we're
constructing that theory,
is for a continuous
function, we define a number
associated to a
partition, which we
interpret as approximate areas.
We would like to say these
approximate areas converge
to some number as the
partitions get finer and finer,
or as the norm gets
smaller and smaller.
And that limiting
number we interpret
as the area
underneath the curve.
That will be what we do
next time, is actually show
the existence of
this limiting number,
which is the Riemann
integral of f.
And we'll stop there.